das sieht auf diesem problem war so
riesig außen und im endeffekt ist dann
somit kommt dann so ein kleines ding
raus war es jetzt wenn man das
anschließt hier der passiert auch noch
perfekt in ein zimmer
der gedanke warum wunschprodukt der
jugendliche dann raus david und herzlich
willkommen bei einem nein das war falsch
und alkohol angefangen du fängst du was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video heute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut mikrofon ist an
oder ist vielleicht heute habe ich was
wirklich sehr interessantes vor
ich würde sagen wir gehen mal kurzem ein
zimmer oder er gleicht und weiter okay
deswegen kann man mit guten alles
wahnsinnig machen ja leute wir befinden
uns hier in meinem zimmer sieht das vom
nicht sehr gut aus und hier habe ich
eigentlich immer meinen pc stehen und
den habe ich jetzt halt ins wohnzimmer
gestellt weil wir da sein und eigentlich
ein kleines arbeitszimmer ausgemacht
haben und man muss ja sagen so mein
zimmer an sich ist damit voll zufrieden
aber es fehlen vielleicht auch so das
ein oder andere detail womit man das
ganze noch so ein bisschen interessanter
gestalten kann und deswegen dachte ich
komm du auch sehr viel ruß videos online
gestellt bestellt sich doch einfach mal
irgendwelche sachen für dein zimmer
also ich hab halt so nach so hohe sachen
gesucht und habe da einige bestellt
darum geht es heute und deswegen würde
ich sagen die mir jetzt erstmal zurück
ins wohnzimmer ich zeige euch die ganzen
sachen und dann schauen wir mal ob wir
das irgendwie hier gut integrieren
können ich habe auf jeden fall ganz
verrückte sachen gestellt aber auch so
standard sachen wie ein teppich und
teppich von muss kann das funktionieren
aber nicht ich weiß es nicht wir werden
sich diesmal ganz stumpf hiermit an
da freue ich mich glaube ich sogar fast
zerreißt und drauf anders ist das soweit
ich fand das sehr interessant und zwar
habe ich letztens als wir beim
kreisklassen für april waren wir nur
zusammen abends auf einem geguckt und in
dieser hütte wo die bohnen waren halt
auch diese leondinger und ich habe mir
für mein zimmer moment den kaktus und
habe mich glaube ich zehn euro gekostet
eine halte ich fest und ananas gestellt
8 ist so erreicht zum aufhängt ist zum
hinstellen interessant haben wir noch
batterien
ja wo sind die alle hin
ich kenne ich habe dir aus gesehen läuft
die leute auf den grünen gelten
okay leute ich hab das jetzt hinbekommen
ok sieht meister sich zeitgleich das
sieht richtig weiß was hast du für
bezirk 10 euro ok kommen wir zum
nächsten produkt das problem ist nämlich
in meinem zimmer
ich habe einen teppich der ist extrem
scheiße dann habe ich mir meine eltern
zum geburtstag geschenkt und erhard so
als immer wenn man drüber geht bleiben
so diese wie sagt man diese fan vom
teppich an den füßen kleben deswegen
dachte ich du brauchst x 9
und ich habe mir für 15 euro eingestellt
und dachte das wird bestimmt gute
qualität sein oder
[Musik]
sieht aus wie so eine ganze garde die
eltern können wir eigentlich warten dann
tun
ich würde nicht wissen wie denn nach
einem monat ausgibt unterricht
eigentlich gut
ich mag kommt glaube ich aus einer
hochwertigen teppichfabrik nicht als
nächstes ich dachte mir so ich bin ja
jemand ich stehe sofort bilder weise und
da habe ich mir ein paar picasso-gemälde
bestellt soll ich dir immer wieder mit
harry hole blinder dass wir schon nimmt
das ja was soll ich damit machen
guck mal sogar auf leinwand das finde
ich geil kampf neumann
das sind hier so bilder kommen hängt man
nebeneinander sowie bei dem produktfoto
hast dich immer kurz einwände und dann
ist das auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
oder
was willst du damit ausdrücken nackte
frau gefangen in der dusche spitze der
frau ich will da kommt man zur nächsten
wache der partie wirklich so umbauen
weil das ist wirklich also ich freue
mich richtig dass in meinem zimmer
hängen zu haben
wahrscheinlich wird manchmal müssen
abhaken ihr könnt dann auch ins
wohnzimmer hängen aber du weißt immer
direkt wie viel uhr es ist ja ich weiß
das ist was seine leuchtenden buchstaben
uhr daniel diese ja genau die buchstaben
o was dabei kinder sterben oder das
macht sein helfer das war hoch
das sieht auf diesem produkt so riesig
aus und im endeffekt ist dann somit
kommt dann so einen kleinen kleines ding
hier raus weil es jetzt wenn man das
anschliesst soll ich bin absolut
überfordert wir haben das jetzt
angeschlossen hier an den strom so ein
bisschen keine ahnung da war sogar eine
knopf batterie dabei wofür ist die
zimmer 13 uhr hier guckt und jetzt geht
das aber wieder weg woran liegt das sind
verstehe er gar nicht nein ich will kein
wecker kannst ja auch ein wecker stellen
ich will aber nur die uhrzeit okay es
hat das halbwegs funktioniert
juli hat es eingestellt ich hatte selber
nicht hinbekommen muss ehrlich sagen
13.15 jetzt gleich auch ein uhr 15 also
derzeit die ganzen kommen hier jetzt mal
eine 15 und sogar auch die gradzahl aber
gut wir lassen es erstmal hier stehen
und eine dazu
auch feuchte was kassel das mit peter
fix rechts oben auf das köln bild kleben
wir machen und zu guter letzt haben wir
hier so ich bin euch immer das foto ein
da kann man seinen schlüssel drauf an
wer sowas nicht schöner machen
damit kann man sowas nicht schöner
machen die sache rechtlich gesehen was
isst du musst sagen ach so ja das ist
ein regenschirm übrigen begehen das war
mein zimmer dass man hier mit anfangen
und dann schauen wir mal ob wir
irgendwas ob es dann am ende cool
aussieht so weißt du die ganze sache was
erwarte ich muss noch was warum ich habe
nämlich gedacht so hier so groß war so
eine kleine staffelung weist das könnte
doch ganz gut aus einem briefkasten
schlüssel ist so wir haben jetzt alle
beklebt jetzt kommt ich hierhin komme
ein bisschen mehr leicht gestaffelt 1
weil das tier dann wisst ihr auch
wirklich benutzt
also irgendwie sieht hier ein bisschen
ski aber warte jetzt hole ich mal kurz
mein schlüssel was auch irgendwie passte
und dieser teppich hier der hase kannst
hier sehen da geht immer alles kann es
ist der horror wirklich und deswegen
darf ich bestelle ich mir mal auf ganz
entspannten neuen teppich
das sieht cacau ich das mit kaka geraten
durch den rollen gerade einfach
[Musik]
übrigens gerade rein ja gut besser geht
es herrlich sorry also ist also was
willst du machen so irgendwie ein
bisschen nach ich bin mit to slide
ehrlich so klar die sachen sind ganz
lustig aber das ist cool aussieht ich
glaube da sind wir noch ganz weit von
entfernt
das einzige womit ich hier bis jetzt
zufrieden bin ist die ananas das ist
doch ganz geil aus oder
naja jetzt habt ihr uhr wenn es dunkel
ist es gar nicht mal so schlimm aus muss
man sagen die uhr will ich da oben drauf
bauen hier der passt jetzt auch noch
perfekt in ein zimmer
dank warum wunschprodukt der b jugend
dann raus hierfür habe ich mir einen
ganz speziellen platz überlegt und zwar
hier gefällt es dir was man eigentlich
ganz auf der kamera sie mal ran
das kabel ist halt echt scheiße aber das
muss nicht über diesen 23
keine ahnung aber wahrscheinlich dann
kannst du immer schön auf stehen auf dem
bett muss ihn herlaufen
es ist dann fehlen jetzt noch diese
bezaubernden bildern die kommen hier
glaube ich meinen fernseher musik leben
da habe ich schon eine gute idee die
frage ist ob das jetzt schon machen
können das ist jetzt noch nicht so krass
wenn ihr aber sagt er mache auf jeden
fall noch weitere folgen davon geht der
daumen nach oben bei 5000 klicks machen
wir das und was ich auch gedacht hat
marie schaute ich meine videos damit sie
nicht einfach süchtig wird kann man hier
auf den kopf von ihr draufkleben das
machen wir dann auch im nächsten jahr in
der gerade heute sieht man hier die
waffen anders also ist also
50 euro kostet die rennen denken das
nimmt ihr fünfter werde das manchen
tischen auf den produktfotos war ich
auch nicht mit behörden haben die jungs
waren
rechts bisschen runter und schnell
wieder licht ausmachen dann sieht es
vielleicht besser aus leute wir machen
jetzt noch ein paar juli schutz von
diesen artikel hier
und dann könnt ihr mal in die kommentare
schreiben welches euch am besten gefällt
also ich bin eigentlich ein fan von
riegel
[Musik]
auch wenn ich nicht ganz zufrieden bin
muss ich ehrlich sagen ich war mit dem
letzten willen spart auf jeden fall
deutlich zufriedener da haben wir led
produkte getestet dann auch auf jeden
fall ab ist jetzt gleich hier verlinkt
ansonsten war es das morgen und neues zu
sehen wir uns wieder gibt es neue ceo
edeka nach blockieren im november hat
die alex ii kam auch ein neues foto oh
ja ich freue mich haut rein
[Musik]